[Applause]
thank you all right
all right
here are the overtime questions
uh for Ollie as a business and economics
reporter do you think it's wise for
corporations to take stances on divisive
issues that can possibly cause Financial
blowback oh well that's certainly much
in the news these days yeah look I think
there's a couple issues here it's uh we
have a you were talking about
immigration earlier immigration is an
imperative because we have uh we have a
worker problem in this country we are
short of workers we were short of
workers before the pandemic so what you
find with companies despite the Gen z uh
students with whom the young people with
whom you have some concerns they don't
have loyalty to their company so
companies find that they have to do
things that satisfy these employees in
order to keep them and not keep churning
through them and one of the things one
of the biggest things that that polling
and surveys by companies show that
workers want right now is their
companies to take positions on matters
that are important to them so the bottom
line is there's a there's an imperative
by employers by consumers for companies
to take positions the other part of it
is that as we've talked about Congress
isn't getting a lot of this right
they're not figuring out nor our state
government's figuring out where these
lines are on complicated socio-political
and socioeconomic issues so I actually
think companies are are a good place
right now to see some of this leadership
it's going to be complicated they're
going to make mistakes they're going to
get in trouble by the public and they're
going to get in trouble by Ron DeSantis
and a bunch of Governors but the bottom
line is I think it's a good development
the companies are waiting their way into
politics they were always there anyway
with their paychecks with their donation
checks now they're getting there and
actually talking directly to what the
problems are
totally
do you know do you know any uh anyone
who actually runs a company because I
don't know anyone who runs a company who
doesn't [ __ ] hate the Gen Z and
Millennials in their office
whether you like it or not yeah I'm just
saying I'm just saying not this one we
have the Fantastic kids here no really
we do but that's because we we don't
hire [ __ ] you know uh and we don't
need we don't need we don't need many
you know it's only a few people
but I'm telling you it is a subject that
is often comes up at dinner in this town
but you know privately you know people
would not say it out loud but they think
it's just a nightmare they're too
sensitive you know they don't want to
come to work anymore because of covet
the people who are least likely to die
from it are still the most afraid of it
um I don't know so I don't think it's
just the Gen Z though it's just the
employees I mean look it Corporate
America should be leaders they really
should be leaders and if that means
taking a difficult stand then don't go
on it they want their Congressman they
want their senator they want their
governor to take courageous they they
need to step up and do the same thing
I'm just saying they hate working with
people who don't have a sense of humor
everything is its subject for you know I
can't believe you said that I'm offended
HR how dare you a tremendous sense of
entitlement about where they should be
in the company it's like you just
started Tuesday yes
sometimes you just have to get the
coffee for a while I'm just I'm just
saying that again not this is not my
life but I hear it all the time I'm just
I'm just a reporter just a humble
reporter
uh okay uh according to the Pentagon
report the U.S Left Behind seven billion
dollars in military equipment
Afghanistan that's low for us when we
when we when we leave after a loss
uh I don't I don't I don't know what the
numbers are for Iraq and Vietnam I think
that's I think this is an improvement
I'm not sure I I I do seven billion that
seems were pretty good for us uh who or
what do you blame for this
well okay well what do you blame for
this who or what do you blame for this I
mean I guess the one obvious ends would
be the Pentagon you know look we we've
been we've we fought that war for 20
years yeah and equipment is going and
going every year and they continue to
throw money at it and it's and no one
would cut it off so I think there's a I
think there's blame to go across numbers
of administrations Congress uh the same
way I mean this is not one person this
is not Joe Biden's fault this is a
combination of things that have gone on
for more than 20 years and
pursuant to the thing I was just doing
about the money that went out the door
for kofit and the hundreds and hundreds
of billions of dollars this is seven
billion I mean we lose that in the couch
yeah I mean you know the Pentagon are
you kidding I mean the biggest
boondoggle of all the biggest problem
here is where it goes right as the
senator
was full of everything you can imagine
trucks and every kind of vehicle you
need and the taliban's quite grateful
for it at the moment I'm sure they are
absolutely and and by the way there's a
flip side to your monologue about the
fraud in the covet packages there is a
flip side because I did a lot of that
fraud is good no no no but but there is
a flip side watch what you didn't what
you didn't talk about when the thief was
going around what how much was still
left on the shelves in that Walmart how
no look wow that is a different way to
look at it no no
well here's another I'm not sure that
that is a winning strategy for
attendance
I might just sell that wasn't no no on
your shelves you're missing the point I
guess I am all right so here's the thing
now here's the thing
first of all I totally agree with you
that Democrats and Republicans ought to
be screaming about the fraud that's
occurred and demanding that the inter
attorney general demanding that the
inspector General really go after that
quick there's no question about that but
this came up like that and Congress was
trying to figure out ways to pass things
that would save this economy and they
did you cannot get around I mean during
World War II that came up pretty fast
too no no no no it didn't we have been
watching World War II develop there was
no even though it was Pearl Harbor we've
been watching but we didn't believe it
when World War II started we were
incredibly unprepared that's why Pearl
Harbor happened because they were
sleeping because she didn't think it was
possible they had to start a new army
they they closed the car factories just
so they could turn them build up they
didn't make any cars except for cars for
generals to ride around right for
elected three years so you know when
people do want to sacrifice and they had
a a commission that prosecuted War
profiteering
people didn't get away with any of this
[ __ ] back then it's about will it's not
about that it came up fast and you're
assuming that there's not going to be
any prosecutions and I just disagree
with that of this amount of money of
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars I don't know where it will be
but there will be a number why did it
happen in the first but it's like you
know nobody can do anything because
people to some extent are just no damn
good you're gonna get criminals I know
where are the people watching it where
are the isn't there someone in a
government office who says oh look I see
we're sending out a farm check to a
state that has no Farms
that kind of thing oh I see these people
are dead we maybe shouldn't say you know
it's not impossible to do that I guess
so the the problem that I had with the
pp program was the way it went through
banks the banks were in SBA was supposed
to be looking at that the banks all of
those loans did not come directly from
secretary mnuchin they came through a
bank they came through a bank and that
if they were using their underwriting
they did the same problem we had in 2008
that's still our system exactly and in
certain other countries including in in
northern Europe where they have systems
where they can get money directly from
the government to either employers or
employees they used a system the
airlines did it instead of the PPP they
used a program where if you continue to
pay your employees we'll give you the
same amount of money so there was no
there was no opportunity for fraud in in
some Industries tax credit correct there
are there are better ways to do this
exactly there are better ways to do it
and the government looks after Banks now
a lot yeah we just have to get out of
the mindset that everything we do has to
go through banks exactly it is
[Applause]